اهلا بكم بينما يعيش المصريون على وقع
ازمه اقتصاديه وانقسام سياسي منذ سنوات
تقفز الى المشهد بين حين واخر قضايا تثير
الجدل تقتحم البيوت وتسيطر على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي هو احد اشكال نظريه
الالهاء الاستراتيجي في نظر فريق من
المتابعين للشان المصري ربما لكن الحقيقه
في جميع الاحوال ان مصر تشهد كما لم يحدث
في اي عهد سابق حمله انتقلت من النقد الى
السباب الذي يستهدف مرجعيات دينيه وشخصيات
تاريخيه محفوره في الوعي العام ما الذي
يحدث في مصر الان اذا نبحث معكم ومع
ضيوفنا عن اجابه والبدايه بتقرير فاطمه
تريكي صلاح الدين واحد من احقر الشخصيات
في التاريخ الانساني احقر الشخصيات صلاح
الدين الايوبي الناصر في موروث العرب
الشهم الشجاع حتى في هوليود اكثر مواقع
تنميط وتشويههم ينعت بنعت معيب على
الشاشات وفي القاهره موطن الازهر ل يتقلب
صلاح الدين حيث يرقد منذ ثمانيه قرون ولن
تهتز مكانته الرفيعه في وجدان امته
والمحترمه حتى عند خصومه بسباب يتلبس
النقد التاريخي بيد ان المختلفه في احدث
محاولات الربط بين التاريخ الاسلامي حصرا
وبين العنف انه ارتفع من العوام وصائد
الشهره الى اكاديمي وروائي يصف صلاح الدين
بالمملوك الكردي في تعبير لا يخلو من غمز
عنصري ومعه الظاهر بيبرز وقطز وعبد الرحمن
الداخل وغيرهم بانهم سفاحون متعطشون
للدماء بحسب تعبير يوسف زيدان وتصويب على
صلاح الدين كمقاتل بالدرجه الاولى تخرجه
من حاله الاثر المندثر الى تاطير ذي صله
لا تخفى بالواقع فهو الذي وحد العرب
والمسلمين وتصدى للحملات الصليبيه الغربيه
واعاد القدس لاهلها بمن فيهم المسيحيون
وابقى كنائسهم وهنا يحضر كلام سابق لزيدان
عن الاقصى يشكك فيه ان يكون في القدس احنا
مش عارفين ان سيدنا محمد بعد ما ضيقو في
قريش راح دع في الطائف نعم وعلى طريق
الطائف في مسجدين مسجد اسمه المسجد الادنى
ومسجد اسمه المسجد الاقصى وهذه نفسها
روايه اسرائيليه فندها مؤرخون مسلمون وعرب
وتبقى خطورتها براي كثر في مدلولها
السياسي اذ تقفز على يقين الاحقيه بارض
مدسه وطعن فكره احتلالها في مواجهه
اسرائيل التي تعرف نفسها بانها يهوديه
ارضا وكيانا ما ينظر اليه باعتباره صراع
هويات اعمق من امتار الارض منذ اربع سنوات
والحاله تتصاعد في مصر تحت رايه مناهضه
الاسلام السياسي وقد خرجت من الايام
الاولى اطروحه الهويه
مغنه مصر المؤمنه قبل التاريخ في دم
عمرنا ما حنبقى زيك ولن تحك زينا ل غنمك
او جمالك بين غوص لردها فرعونيه وتنميط عن
ابل واغنام تحيط بصوره المسلم المسيس
توالت دعوات لاقفال الازهر وتغيير مناهج
التعليم الديني في واقع ابعد ما يكون عن
طرف التفكير والبحث فهذه مصر التي تغرق في
العنف والقمع السياسي امام انظار نخب ايدت
او صم صمت القبور قبل ان تنصرف للنبش في
قبور السالفين وكان حالها يقول ان لم تجر
على انتقاد جنرال في الحكم فاشتم رمزا في
التاريخ
الاسلامي نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيفين هنا
في الاستوديو معي الدكتور سيف الدين عبد
الفتاح استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
القاهره ومن تونس ينضم الينا الدكتور محمد
الحاج سالم الباحث في علم الاجتماع اهلا
بكما وابدا معك دكتور سيف الدين عبد الف
ما يحدث في مصر اليوم من اساءه لشخصيات
دينيه اسلاميه وتشويه للحقائق التاريخيه
هل هو برايك مجرد افكار لكاتب اراد ان
يروج لها ويشيع في المجتمع المصري ام انها
عمليه منظمه ممنهجه لتشويه تاريخنا
الاسلامي انا اعتقد ان هناك يعني امرين
مهمين في هذا الموضوع الامر الاول هو
المتعلق ب في
الانقلاب كل شيء ينقلب حتى التصور الذي
يتعلق بالمسائل التي تتعلق بالدين المسائل
التي تتعلق بالتاريخ كل هذه الامور تكون
مستباحه كاست باحه الناس والامر الثاني هو
ذلك العبث الذي يمارسه بعض المثقفين لا
ادري ان كان ذلك باتفاق مع مع جهات اخرى
تحاول التغطيه على مسائل فيما يتعلق بمعاش
الناس وكل الامور التي تتعلق بازمات
وضعتهم
واحتياجاتهم وبين الامر الذي يتعلق
بسياسات بيع الارض كما هو في موجود في لدى
السيسي في هذا الانقلاب والمسائل كلها
تتعدد من ارتفاع الاصحار وغيره هو يريد ان
كما تقدمت حضرتك بسياسه الالهاء
الاستراتيجي التي تحدث عنها نعوم تشومسكي
يعني حاله الالهاء الاستراتيجي هذه ان صح
توصيف ما يحدث الان في مصر
بها هل الهدف منها فقط هو تحقيق تلك
الغايات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والسياسيه
للنظام الانقلابي في مصر اليوم ام ان هناك
هدف فعلا في تشويه هذه الشخصيات وهذا تراث
التارخ طبعا هذا هو ما يترتب على مثل هذه
المسالتين اللي احنا بنتكلم عنهم وهو ان
مساله التشويه اصبحت عمليه ممنهجه ومنظمه
بالنسبه للرموز في التاريخ والمؤسسات في
الدين
وال والمناهج في
التعليم والتاريخ والعبث به كل هذه الامور
تتم
هكذا كما يقولون على عينك يا تاجر انقل
هذه الافكار الى ضيفنا من تونس الدكتور
محمد الحاج سالم وهو باحث في علم الاجتماع
الدكتور محمد الحاج سالم عندما تتم
الاساءه الى من يعتبر في الذاكره العربيه
والاسلاميه قائدا تاريخيا كصلاح الدين
الايوبي وبالنظر الى الظروف والمعطيات
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والسياسيه
والامنيه كذلك التي تعيشها مصر كيف يمكننا
ان نوصف
ذلك الحقيقه انه هذه العمليه يعني ليست
بنت بنت
وهذا التاريخ اللحظه التاريخيه الراهنه
يعني شهدنا
عده احداث او وقائع من هذا القبيل يعني في
طوال القرن العشر في في مصر وفي غير وفي
غير مصر لا ادري ان كانت عمليه ممنهجه
للتيه كما قال ضيفك الكريم لكن انا اعتقد
انه فيه ضرب حتى لرميه السيسي ذاتها يعني
اذا كان الغرض منها تلهيه الناس عن
المشاكل الواقعيه مشاكل الاقتصاديه
واجتماعيه وخاصه السياسيه عبر هذه الطريقه
عبر ضرب رمز من رموز التاريخ العربي
الاسلامي وضرب زعامه صوره
يعني دعني دعني اقول متخيله ومسطره لهذه
الزعامه التاريخيه فهي ضرب لكل الزعامات
بما فيها الزعامات المصريه يعني حين يشار
مثلا يوسف زيدان حين يشيروا الى دمويه
بين مزدوجين القائد الفذ صلاح الدين
الايوبي هذا يعني يركز الانظار على على ما
ما يتم الان من دمويه يعني
فيده سيد محمد الحاج سالم ما هو التاثير
اذا المراد تحقيقه من خلال تشويه صوره هذه
الشخصيات التي تعتبر في الذاكره العربيه
والاسلاميه قائده
وقدوه و اسقاط ذلك على الواقع الحالي
المعاش في مصر
تحديدا نعم هنا يقع السؤال لا ادري يعني
بالضبط ما هو الغرض من ذلك ان كان الغرض
علميا بعثا يعني بحثا تاريخيا فتوصي قائد
فذ مثل صلاح الدين الايوبي بانه شخصيه
[__] هذا ليس لا يدخل في باب البحث
العلمي هذا التوصيف غير تاريخي البته هو
توصيف اخلاقي يعني يسقط عليه احكاما وقيما
معاصره والحال انه يعني هذه الشخصيه عاشت
في ابستم اخرى في مناخ معرفي اخر الاحكام
تختلف من حقبه زمنيه الى اخرى ان نقول على
صلاح الدين الايوبي انه ارتكب جرائم ضد
الانسانيه فهذا حكم يعني حدثي بين مزدوجين
لا يمكن اسقاطه على شخصيه تاريخيه فذه لها
في متخيل رمزيه كبرى اذا هناك اهداف لكل
هذه الضجه وكل هذه الاساءه دكتور سيف
الدين عبد الفتاح هي عمليه ممنهجه كما
وصفتها
ربما اضيف الى كلامك جمله معطيات ما سرب
من يوسف زيدان نفسه عندما قال انه يروج
لهذه الافكار بتوجيهات من الرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي نفسه وكذلك ما ذكره السيسي
نفسه في خطابه قبل عامين عندما دعى الى
تصحيح اخطاء او مفاهيم دينيه اعتبرها هو
خاطئه واحداث ثوره دينيه في مصر ما الذي
يصبو اليه في النهايه انا اظن ان هذه
المساله مساله الى جانب ما تحدثنا عنه من
اشتغال
الناس هناك مساله اساسيه تتعلق
بتشويه الذاكره التي تتعلق بعالم
المسلمين المنقلب هو من قال بتعبيرات
واضحه ان المليار و600 مليون هم سبب
الماسي في كل الدنيا وليس لهم ان ينغصه
حياه هؤلاء الذين يسكنون ويقطنون العالم
اظن ان هذه الروح
التي ونسمع في الغرب كلام اخر نسمع تفرقه
غايه في الاهميه ما بين الاسلام
والارهاب ليس من الصحيح ان تحدث مثل هذه
الامور التي تجعل هناك تما
ما بين الاسلام والارهاب بهذا الشكل الذي
وايضا ما يقوم به يوسف زيدان في هذا
الاطار انما قال من قبله في القدس وقال
انه نسق ذلك مع قائد الانقلاب و ومع
اجهزته وانه الان ايضا يقول وخد من شت هذا
احق رجل في التاريخ ربما المصطلحات
المستخدمه هي التي استدعت التوقف عند هذه
الضجه المثاره دكتور محمد الحاج سالم من
تونس هناك من يرى في المقابل بان اعاده
مراجعه التاريخ وشخصيات والرموز التراثيه
والتاريخيه لابد منه في فتره من الفترات
ما مدى منطقيه هذا الطرح
اليوم نعم هذا امر مطلوب يعني البحث يعني
مطلوب منا كباحثين عرب ان نعيد قراءه
التاريخ لكن قراءه التاريخ بنفس الروائي
هو غير قراءه التاريخ نس علمي ما يتولاه
يوسف زيدان هو يعني قراءه بعين الروائي
يعني هو يقع في تناقض كبير حين يزعم مثلا
ان الصوره التي ظهر عليها الناصر صلاح
الدين في فيلم في شريط يوسف شهين الناصر
صلاح الدين هي بعيده عن التاريخ ينسى انه
هذه روايه غير تاريخيه هي رؤيه فنيه
لوقائع تاريخيه لرمز تاريخي هو يقع في
تناقض هناك ومحل تناقضه انه هو نفسه في
روايته عزازيل يتبنى وقائع تاريخيه ويبني
رؤيه فنيه هل قالت هيباتيا ما قالته حقا
في التاريخ كواقع بالطبع لا هذا يعني
الزيدان يوسف زيدان ينطق عبر بطله روايته
نفس الشيء يعني في الفيلم حين ننتقد يوسف
شاهين ونقول ان ناصر صلاح الدين هذه
الشخصيه السينمائيه ليست هي نفسها الشخصيه
تاريخيه هذا عادي
جدا تت دكتور محمد الحاج سالم الاسلوب
الذي يقوم به هؤلاء الكتاب بانتقاد هذه
الشخصيات القدوه والشخصيات التي ربما في
الوعي المصري من الصعب تحريكها انقل هذه
الفكره للدكتور سيف الدين عبد الفتاح من
الذي يفترض ان يقف في وجه حملات التشويه
والاساءه هذه ضد رموز تاريخيه اسلاميه في
مصر مؤسسه الازهر التي هي ايضا في عين
العاصفه انا اعتقد انه ما يحدث الان ليس
بالمراجعات ولكنها حاله من حالات التشكيك
والتشويه والسباب الذي يكال شخصيات رمزيه
في حاجه اسمها الذاكره الرمزيه هو يريد ان
يطمس هذه الذاكره بشكل من الاشكال لانه
هذا المنقلب هو اسوا من اسوا اي قائد اتى
على مصر في هذا التاريخ ومن ثم هو يريد ان
يشكك في كل هذه القيادات التاريخيه ليس
هناك واحنا بنقول صلاح الدين الايوبي هو
الميزان الذي يتعلق بامه المسلمين هو
القدس حينما يعيد صلاح الدين الايوبي
القدس الى احضان هذه الامه فان ذلك ه
سهوله ان ان ياخذ هذا الطريق او هذا
الكلام طريقه الى المواطن المصري البسيط
ويتغلغل لا طبعا انا عاوز اقول لحضرتك انه
التدين الفطري وكل هذه الاشياء من الصعب
اقتلاعها هم يخوضون مع ضد التيار وضد
الفطره وضد الوعي الفطري وكل هذه الامور
دكتور سيف الدين عبد الفتاح استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه القاهره والدكتور محمد
الحاج سالم الباحث في علم الاجتماع من
تونس شكرا جزيلا لكما وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا
على متابعه ملفات الحصاد لهذه الليله الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ه